[Music]
ruin American Idol but a huge event this
weekend we got a new American princess
did you guys watch The Royal Wedding
coverage what do you think of it well
let me just date myself from out okay I
remember when I had them lady died and I
was it was amazing and now to see them
both married she would be very proud I
must tell you I mean it's a it's a
moment in time but I'm glad to see that
they're moving on as young men as family
man I love it I I don't know much about
her but what I've seen or heard whether
it's been true or false everything to me
it sounds amazing and I'm I'm so happy
for them and it's amazing what she's
doing with all this her humanitarian
efforts you know the fact that she's a
proud feminist I love all that so I
support her as another woman and love
her and wish them both well well and you
serve looks every week on American Idol
what did you guys think of the dress
thoughts on the dress I would have done
one more fitting of course let me take
that dress Kate Kate Kate one I'm sorry
I'm never not going to tell the truth
one more fitting
you